detectives in louisiana are
investigating a black teenager's death
as a homicide but his family says
police are not doing enough kawan bobby
charles was 15 years old he was found
dead days after he was reported missing
family members believe that officers did
not take his disappearance seriously
because of his race there was no amber
alert in his case but police claim
all procedures were followed our
national correspondent jerica duncan
spoke with the teenagers cousins
and attorneys people are angry people
are upset
kawan charles's cousin selena charles
says her family wants answers in the 15
year old's death
and the investigation that followed the
charles family says kawan was picked up
on
october 30 by this woman janet irvin and
her 17 year old son
they allegedly picked him up outside his
father's house in baldwin louisiana
his parents say they didn't know the
woman or her son
and never consented to him leaving with
him when kawan's
family reported him missing they say
police brushed off their concerns
and speculated kuwan was at a football
game do you believe race
played a role in how this case has been
investigated so far
most definitely you know because they
didn't notify the media
they didn't notify the community on
november 2nd the 15 year old's body was
found in a sugar cane field in
laurelville 30 minutes from his home
the coroner's office says the teen
likely drowned and had no injuries
before his death
they also ruled that the wounds on his
face happened after his death
and were likely caused by aquatic
animals but according to the family's
attorneys
the water in the sugar cane field is
very shallow
those bodies of water barely go up to
your your knees
and so this isn't that quan trying to go
for a swim
the attorneys say janet irvin and her
son have since packed up
and left their home investigators say
they have questioned the individuals
believed to have been with kawan before
he disappeared
and are actively tracking their
whereabouts local activist jamal taylor
helped the family raise over 250
thousand dollars through gofundme
for the family to hire its own
investigators and get a second autopsy
i was particularly disappointed by the
the lack of response from police in the
matter
and so i immediately said we need to do
something about this it shouldn't be
incumbent upon the family to solve the
crime of quan charles
family members are now drawing
similarities between charles injuries
and emmett tills
in 1955 two white men murdered 14 year
old till
for allegedly whistling at a white woman
in mississippi
his casket was left opened at his
mother's request
so the world could see the brutality the
charles family released a photo of kawan
to show the world what he looked like
when he was found
what made you all release that image
well we felt like the world needed to
see
we have opted not to show that image of
kawan due to the graphic
nature and also the ongoing
investigation now the sheriff's office
that is investigating this case did
release a statement this weekend saying
they have video of kawan apparently
walking alone around the time of his
disappearance
but they have not released that video to
the public
we also reached out to janet irvin and
have not heard a response back gail
boyd eureka just reading about the
injuries that was done to quan
made me nauseous or i have mixed
feelings about showing that picture we
know it made a difference in the emmett
till case
but do you know if the urbans had any
connection to this this young man
they didn't know each other that they
did not know this family the
the family kawan's parents say they did
not know this woman
they did not know the son they don't
understand how this happened and
ultimately they want answers yeah we
want more answers and they were hoping
that the police they said did
more early on in this that's what they
were hoping yeah this story is not over
we'll stay on top of it thank you jerica
yeah